الاخضر يشير حماسه العرب في المونديال
ميريام فارس تعتذر ليله اصاله في موسم
الرياض جديد سلطان الطرب قلق حول صحه
انغام وخبر صادم عن منه شلبي اليكم الابرز
في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
تصدرت اخبار بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم
في قطر عناوين الاعلام وقائمه المواضيع
الرائجه في مواقع التواصل عالميا الاسبوع
الماضي وكان من ابرزها واكثرها تفاعلا في
العالم العربي الفوز التاريخي للمنتخب
الوطني السعودي على منتخب الارجنتين الذي
يقوده ميسي احد اساطير كره القدم
المعاصرين
[تصفيق]
اصابه بالغه تعرض لها احد نجوم المنتخب
السعودي ياسر الشهراني اجريت له على اثرها
عمليه تكللت في النجاح لكنها ابعدته عن
المشاركه فيما تبقى من نهائيات كاس العالم
2022 وقد تم انا وزير الرياضه السعوديه
عبد العزيز بن تركي الفيصل متابعي سي ان
ان على حاله الشهراني الصحيه
عندها
الحمد لله وحمل النجوم المنتخب السعودي
قميصه ياسر الشهراني في لفته تفاعل معها
جمهور الاخضر في مستهلي مباراه السعوديه
مع بولندا التي لم تجري الرياحها بما
تشتهي سفن السعوديين وانتهت بخسارتهم امام
بولاند لكن الجمهور السعودي الهزيمه ويقف
بحماس وراء منتخب الوطني في مباراتهم
المرتقبه مع المكسيك التي يعلقون عليها
امانه كبيره لبلوغ دوري 16 وربما
من ذلك بحسب ما رصد فريق سيان ام بالعربيه
في الدوحه اثناء تغطياتهم لاخبار
المونديال اولا باول
16 همم كل تاخيره في اخيره بنتاهل عن طريق
بوابه المكسيك ان شاء الله
النهايه هذه النهايه كل عدد الحديث يلا
يلا انا متوقعها باذن الله يعني ما يفشنا
باذن الله
[موسيقى]
بصراحه يعني هذا مشروع كثير حلو مشروع
صرنا خمس سنين عم بنحضر له
كاس العالم ميريام فارس الجدل الذي طال
تصريحاتها حول مده التحضيرات لونيه
تكوتاكا التي تم اصدارها بمناسبه كاس
العالم للشراكه بينها وبين نيكي ميناج
ومالوما وذلك في تغريده نشرته الفنانه
اللبنانيه عبر حسابها الرسمي على تويتر
اوضحت فيها ان التحضير لهذا الحدث اخذ
خمسه اشهر واعتذر عن قولها خمس سنوات في
احدى المقابلات سهوا بحسب تعبيرها وتوجهت
بالشكر لكل من سندها لكلمه حلوه
ومن الدوحه حيث ترقص قلوب عشاق كره القدم
على ايقاع المونديال الى موسم الرياض الذي
يواكب بطوله كاس العالم والمنتخب الوطني
السعودي بفعاليات خاصه الى جانب فعالياته
الترفيهيه المستمره وكان من ابرزها
الاسبوع الماضي ليله المطربه اصاله التي
حقق التفاعل على مواقع التواصل في المملكه
[موسيقى]
ومن مصر وبعد حفله في الاسكندريه اعلن
السلطان الطرب جورج وسوف عن اصدار اغنيته
الجديده بيتكلم عليها من كلمات اميرتي
والحان زياد برجي وذلك في فيديو كليب من
اخراج اليسا معان شارك فيه الفنانين
السوريين عابد فهد وعبد المنعم عمايري
والفنانه اللبنانيه
في الشكر عبر حساباته الرسميه على مواقع
التواصل لصناع الاغنيه ولجمه على تفاعلهم
مع الاعلان عنها الذي راى فيه حبا كبيرا
بحسب تعبير
لكن بعض اخبار اهل الفن في مصر لم تكن
سعيده وصادمه ايضا حيث اقلقت المطربه
المصريه انغام محبيها على وضعها الصحيه
بعد ما نشر مكتبها الاعلامي عبر حساباتها
الرسميه على مواقع التواصل بيانا اعلن فيه
عن تعرضها لوعكه صحيه طارئه اضطرت بعدها
لاجراء عمليه جراحيه كبيره ادت الى
مضاعفات تطلبه وقائها في المستشفى وطالب
البيان جمهورها ومحبها بالدعاء لها كما
تصدرت الفنانه المصريه منه شلبي العناوين
الفنيه في العالم العربي وترند على مواقع
التواصل بعد ما نشرته وسائل الاعلام مصريه
عن القبض عليها في مطار القاهره لدى
عودتها من الولايات المتحده بتهمه حيازه
مواد مخدره بعد ذلك اعلنت النيابه العامه
المصريه مساء الجمعه عن قرار اخلاء سبيل
منه شلبي بضمان مالي قدره 50,000 جنيها
وارسال المواد المضبوطه بحوزتها بمطار
القاهره بمصلحه الطب الشرعي لفحصها وبيان
طبيعتها ومدحتوائها على اي من المواد
المخدره
ولم يصدر عن الفنانه المصريه اي تعليق حول
هذه الواقعه لحين اعداد هذه الحلقه